hey gary you want to talk about that why
did the jets suck so bad gary can give
you a like why do why do they suck so
bad they are genuinely the laughing
stock of not only
um football but sports and like they
keep turning up in pop culture
references like even ted lasso made a
joke this season about you know what do
you call a team that's the worst if the
team was playing poorly we don't call
them unlucky what do we call them coach
new york jets and they keep getting
these quarterbacks right they draft
these first round quarterbacks
and then they they they ruin them
you know they they they teach them bad
habits and then they suck
so how come they're so bad is it the
manager is it that team ownership it's
the culture
um they got a general manager who i like
who's trying he said this is his third
year but it's really kind of like a
second year they got a new coach this
year who i really like and i don't know
if they can change the culture i read an
article that said that the owners
listen to the fans too much and like
react to their every move and that
they're always doing stuff but i can't
explain it you know they've had early
draft round picks the last couple of
years
and none of it's turned into much i mean
they won one game this season and i
don't
i don't know that they're gonna win
another game this season so in other
words they get sometimes some good draft
picks and they get into the culture of
the jets and then they suck
yeah but even like even like last year's
draft like people will talk about it the
jets were winless last year right and so
this this quarterback that was the
number one pick they call them like a
once in a generation quarterback and
then the jets went in one two games so
they got the second pick so they even
blew getting the best like they should
have just not won games but but then if
they got this quarterback i don't know
that they wouldn't wreck him
you know what i mean like i don't know
like if the jet straight if the gesture
after tom brady
you know how many 30 years ago i don't
know that tom brady would be tom brady
no they would [ __ ] him up and and and by
the way the jets lost 54 13 to the
patriots and belichick loves crushing
the jets there's a guy from the patriots
he was getting put into their like hall
of fame and he specifically asked to
have it done for a jets game because he
just wanted to rub it in wow it's pretty
amazing to be in an industry and not be
able to play the game you know i mean
really do do they have those owners
conferences where the other guys just
laugh at the people who own the jets it
used to be a thing of honor to be in the
new york area you know used to want to
get to new york now it's like oh [ __ ]
don't put me on new york
well and there's truth to that because i
believe even in the last 10 years there
have been maybe opportunities for trades
or signing free agents where i think
there are people who don't want to be
part of this team
wow yeah that's pretty bad
you